aéroport d'orly dans ce carton sur
mesure un fragment du patrimoine
historique de cuba norbert chassery et
gérard april sont champions de pêche au
gros
les détenteurs d'un trophée mythique la
prestigieuse coupe ernest hemingway
c'est vraiment le graal de la pêche au
gros
après trois victoires en tournoi à cuba
ils ont obtenu le privilège de
l'emporter avec eux en france seule
équipe française à avoir gagné en 59 ans
on est très fiers or il sait il ya
beaucoup de grands pécheurs compte
essayer qui sont cassés les dents dessus
donc là là on a ramé nous et le remet en
jeu ouais
ben là on est parti pour
norbert et gérard la soixantaine sont
informaticiens à la retraite ils
ramènent la coupe chez elle à cuba pour
la remettre en jeu la havane cuba est
sous embargo américain depuis 48 ans
logement transport travail nourriture la
pénurie chronique et le quotidien
difficiles pour les cubains leur tournoi
de pêche au gros est un enjeu important
c'est une des compétitions
internationales qui attire dans l'île
des sportifs du monde entier
alors la pêche peut-elle servir la
diplomatie en aide env le pays
[Musique]
la marina hemingway c'est là que démarre
la 60e édition du tournoi du même nom
créée en 1950 à cuba par l'écrivain
américain ernest hemingway
passionné de pêche c'est une enclave
pour touristes fortunés tamarina les
bateaux les hôtels tout appartient à
l'état pour gérard qui sacrifie tout à
son amour de la pêche
l'enjeu est avant tout sportif pour moi
c'est quelque chose de mythique et
jamais jamais j'aurais pensé un jour
faire la une des journaux avec la coupe
hemingway ça c'est sûr ils m'ont même
femme m'a aidé aussi à la jamais cru en
la victoire donc ça ça m'a motivé aussi
c'est surtout ça qui m'a motivé et il
m'a dit ah vous jour ils arrivent ici il
me dit en faisant la le un jour j'aurai
mon nom gravé sur la coupe chiffres oui
parce qu'il va dire quand les poules
auront des dents
[Musique]
vous y allez on vous attend après avoir
pris soin de leur trophée pendant un an
il leur faut maintenant le rendre aux
cubains la concurrence va être rude
cette année plus de trente équipages de
17 pays différents participent au
tournoi un record
la lie à la claque à tous les grands
pêcheurs qui sont là voilà russe par
voyez les russes italiens type italien
paolo salah
les américains je sais pas où sont les
américains obtenir leur participation
malgré l'embargo c'était la mission de
l'organisateur du tournoi le commodore
et ce riche mais le dégel entre cuba et
les etats unis n'est pas encore
d'actualité
j'ai été en floride au mois de février
et j'ai rencontré des dizaines de
personnes qui souhaitaient participer à
notre tournoi et tout indique que ce
sont les restrictions de voyage qui ne
leur ont pas permis de nous accompagner
cuba est le seul pays au monde que le
gouvernement américain a interdit à ses
ressortissants
trois équipages sont tout de même venus
des états unis malgré le risque de se
voir infliger une amende minimum de 9000
euros
à leur retour c'est le capitaine joseph
vie dans le new-jersey mais ils passent
la moitié de son temps à cuba avec son
capitaine franck pour se rendre ici ils
ont employé une sorte de stratagèmes
avant les garde-côtes nous donnait une
permission pour venir à cuba
officiellement elle ensuite
bush a tout bloqué il ne voulait plus
voir de bateaux américains à cuba alors
on est allé aux bahamas et des bahamas
on prend un vol pour cuba ça fait 16 ans
qu'on fait comme ça sans problème le
lendemain matin les équipages se prépare
pour le premier jour du tournoi
[Musique]
gérard les ses supporters sur le quai
les choses sérieuses vont commencer
première étape à la sortie de la marine
à la douane à cuba la navigation c'est
un secteur sensible au départ et à
l'arrivée
les autorités contrôlent les passagers
et le navire
le problème c'est pas vraiment un
contrôle mais on vérifie que ceux qui
sont sortis sont bien entrés
c'est une certaine couche si on peut
l'appeler comme ça ici tous les jours
ils vérifient bon c'est surtout pour
voir s'il n'y a pas des cubains en
transit qui pourrait repartir sur un
bateau ancré au large
la course se déroule sous surveillance
pour encadrer la zone un remorqueur puis
une vedette militaire les côtes
américaines sont à peine à 150 km et
nombreux sont les cubains qui cherchent
à fuir leur pays
tout est prévu pour l'éviter très
surveillé
les bâtonnets dans les
mais pardon
tous les bateaux sont à l'arrêt départ
imminent
superstitieux gérard parent toujours
avec le même bateau
la même casquette et le même équipage
rodolfo le marin et georgie le capitaine
ça y est c'est parti
c'est parti
c'est parti plein gaz pour lancer les
lignes au plus vite la taille des
hameçons la grosseur du fil
tout est réglementé le gagnant sera
celui qui capturera le plus grand nombre
de marlin ou d'espadon les poissons à
rostrales on est les seuls qui comptent
pour le concours une partie de bluff
s'engage avec eux les leurres simule la
présence de petits poissons pour attirer
les gros le vous mousser derrière le
bateau plus vous faites plus vous faites
remonter les gros poissons
parce qu'ils ont l'impression qu'ils à
une chasse derrière le bateau il ya
mangé qui est allongée à peine une heure
après le départ
première touche un poisson a mordu au
loin un marlin saute au bout de la ligne
[Musique]
il a décroché
ça c'est poisson qu'à gagner
à quelques encablures un concurrent
espagnol d'affairé à son tour un marlin
emprise
pour l'instant il est en train de le
ramener
non non il tient c'est la première
capture du tournoi ça doit être le nôtre
celui là
on aurait pu la voir la chance que
les premiers accroché
ma chambre
belle touche d'entrée de jeu
attention en a
le bonus dont bénéficient ceux qui
pêchent le premier poisson vient de
passer sous le nez des français un peu
plus tard à 15h30 un des quatre
équipages russes fait une touche un
marlin
comme le veut le règlement les pêcheurs
ne capture pas le poisson
ils marquent leur prise puis il la
photographier avec un appareil jetable
remis par le jury il la relâche ensuite
pour préserver les ressources en poisson
[Musique]
pour l'équipage français fin de la
première journée morose
c'est un numéro un n'est pas terrible
pour aujourd'hui
enfin le bidon
retour à la marina pour ceux qui ont
pêché reste à officialiser les prises
les photos reviennent du labo et le jury
se met au travail
cliché après clichés on compte les
points
ça c'est au moment du mariage
là on voit le poisson est là c'est quand
il remonte alors les deux captures de la
journée sont validés cela fait 3 150
points pour les espagnols autant pour
les russes gérard et norbert eux ne
ramène qu'une petite daurade pêcher en
fin de journée il n'a cost pas au ponton
officiel mais se range dans la voie de
garage
grosse déception pour leurs supporters
il a décroché décrocher mais tellement
recchi qui comptent pas le voir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les espagnols ont pris un petit avantage
mais le tournoi ne fait que commencer
le lendemain
relâche girard et norbert emmènent leur
petite troupe de supporters sur les
traces d'ernest hemingway
l'écrivain américain prix nobel de
littérature a découvert cuba au début
des années 30 il est tombé amoureux de
l'île et en 1932 il revient à la
capitale
il a décidé de s'installer à cuba
passionné de pêche sportive il a créé à
la havane le concours qui porte son nom
pendant vingt ans il a résidé dans cette
maison qu'il a achetée en 1940 sur les
hauteurs de la havane
[Musique]
elle est devenue son refuse et son lieu
de création juste en face à regarder la
machine à écrire sa position parce qu'il
écrivait des vous tous les écoliers
cubain connaissent ces ouvrages l'auteur
du vieil homme et la mer est aussi
célèbre et vénéré à cuba parce qu'il ya
tout juste 50 ans son concours de pêche
est entré dans la légende
révolutionnaire c'est l'année face et
ses mythiques le 15 mai 1960 un peu plus
d'un an après la victoire de la
révolution cubaine
l'équipage constitué par fidel castro et
che guevara gagne le concours hemingway
[Musique]
la remise du trophée l'occasion de la
première rencontre entre l'écrivain et
le révolutionnaire moi je suis pas
particulièrement fan de castro mais
c'est quand même historique c'est quand
même il fait partie des grands me choque
et l'anc élan gagner ça me
certaines certains aura la coupe fait
que pendant que monsieur grotte ça qu'il
l'ait gagné
hemingway a soutenu les premiers pas de
la révolution cubaine fidel castro avait
lu ses livres et l'appréciait alors ici
l'écrivain et sa légende sont largement
exploité son bateau le pilar entièrement
restaurée est exposée dans jardin tous
les cubains sont persuadés qu'il ya très
peu d'américains qui a cuba et légumes
c'est pour ça qu'ils génèrent autant et
demi en plus c'est un superbe et
écrivain il a eu le prix nobel et en
plus il a offert samassa médaille du
prix nobel pense que c'est un des liens
qui peuvent faire que ils puissent s'en
rapprocher d'eux
américains et les américains mais cuba
parmi tous les lieux fréquentés par
l'écrivain à la havane dans les années
50 et 60 le plus connu c'est ce bar le
floridita c'est là que dit-on il aurait
inventé le daiquiri un cocktail à base
de rhum de citron et de glace pilée
[Musique]
il était constamment ici est toujours
dans cette position apparemment il
aimait bien
un auteur de bonne chair et d'os bon
vivant dans ces grands moments de
solitude il mais se console est ici la
solitude un point commun tous les
pêcheurs le tournoi reprend mais le
poisson se fait plus rare qu'à
l'habitude
du coup le concours est encore plus
tendue
la première place est à la portée de
tout le monde
c'est vrai je suis optimiste je pense
qu'on peut encore gagner
aucun bateau n'a plus d'une prise on a
encore des possibilités mais j'espère
que la chance va enfin nous sourire
en milieu de journée la chance tourne en
faveur des français un bandeau rade
depuis le bateau
[Musique]
pendant dix minutes c'est la frénésie
la vie de l'homme variable mais les
drames ne rapporte pas de points dans le
concours
ce ne sont pas des poissons à rust
allez on a cette fois son rang quand la
marine à 18,19 d'orage s'est bien amusé
le principal
lola marina marlins 10 on a pris 19
daurade
même minime toutes les prises doivent
être signalées à la marina sa casser la
monotonie
non c'est super on maintenant les gros
vont arriver en attendant les bons
[Musique]
quand un livre
boulot harassant la pêche
à cuba les dorades finissent en général
comme cela mariner avec du jus de citron
et des petits oignons
[Musique]
vous
1er concours parce qu'on a gagné le
dernier jour bien des amis dernier
gérard est confiant toujours pas de
marlin ou d'espadon mais rien n'est
encore joué depuis près de vingt ans
qu'il pêche qui si gérard et norbert
connaissent par coeur les difficultés
des cubains le système d érigée en mode
de vie
les taxis en sont l'illustration les
maintenir en fonctionnement est un
exploit quotidien c'est quoi la marque
chevrolet 1951 et tout est originale oui
sauf le moteur et c'est quoi comme
moteur
très fort encore sur les miracles de
cuba ce
avaya
ce génie de la débrouille permet de
lutter contre les conséquences du blocus
américain et contre la pénurie qui sévit
depuis la chute de l'union soviétique
un système économique à deux vitesses
s'est créée autour des deux millions de
touristes qui visitent le pays chaque
année
une monnaie spéciales distinctes du peso
cubain a été institué pour les étrangers
le cook donc loupé pour le couvain ils
occuperont le touriste on n'a pas le
même niveau de vie le même revenu donc
quelque part qui est pas que c'est
normal
lucas d'argent paye avec un salaire
moyen autour de 15 euros
les cubains peuvent bénéficier de bas
prix en achetant dans les épiceries
d'état comme celle ci mais ils n'ont
droit qu'à un quart de poulet 3 kg de
riz un savon un kilo et demi de sucre
par personne et par mois
tout est consigné dans ce livret de
rationnement la libre et à des
difficultés d'approvisionnement sont
courantes en ce moment il est difficile
de trouver du sel ou du savon c'est la
merde qu'on nous donne ici aux cubains
que tu dis ça aux états unis tout va mal
il faut dire la vérité ça suffit les
mensonges 90% de l'économie est contrôlé
et planifiée par l'état mais depuis
avril 2008 des réformes en libérer
certains secteurs par exemple les
coiffeurs cubain qui ne compte pas plus
de trois fauteuils dans leur salon
peuvent aujourd'hui se mettre à leur
compte comme l'a fait michel
[Musique]
l'état nounou le local nous sommes des
travailleurs indépendants nous
travaillons pour notre propre compte
je ne touche pas de salaire fixe je
gagne en fonction de ce que je fais ici
avant l'état nous verser un salaire mais
ça c'est fini ça marche plus ou moins
bien parce que c'est une expérience
nouvelle
résultats de la loi de l'offre et de la
demande le prix de la coupe a presque
doublé à la havane
nous retrouvons gérard norbert et leur
groupe d'amis qui dînent ce soir là chez
une famille cubaine marié talent ou deux
chambres d'hôtes dans sa maison comme
tous ceux qui travaillent avec les
étrangers sont payés en cuc
elle s'en sort plutôt bien dans ce
système à deux vitesses ça c'est une des
chambres que je loue c'est tout ça on
est en train de tout refaire pour
réaliser ces travaux
elle a embauché deux ouvriers qui comme
beaucoup de gens ici sont obligés de
cumuler deux emplois
mais ce qu'il fait n'est pas son travail
officiel lui il travaille au théâtre je
suis technicien dans le théâtre
je fais la lumière le son je prépare la
scène dans le théâtre du quartier et ce
travail là ne vous suffit pas oui mais
j'ai besoin d'un autre travail
c'est normal normal d'avoir plusieurs
boulots normal aussi les combines pour
garnir les assiettes ce soir marié et a
mis les petits plats dans les grands
pour ses autres français est ce que vous
trouvez de tous au marché oui plus ou
moins il y a le marché mais il ya aussi
marché noir
l'aisance de marietta vient aussi de
l'aide envoyée par la moitié de sa
famille parti vivre aux états unis
le gouvernement cubain a assoupli les
autorisations de voyage
désormais elle peut se rendre là bas
plus souvent maintenant on me donne
davantage d'autorisations tous les deux
ans j'y vais je reste avec eux deux ou
trois mois avec ma famille et aussi ils
peuvent venir et donc c'est mieux
qu'avant oh oui comme ma mère est partie
on a passé 18 années sans communiquer
sans l'être ni téléphone
rien
le régime a lâché du lest mais pas sur
la liberté d'expression à cuba toujours
pas de presse libre pas non plus d'accès
privé à internet
le petit neveu profite quand même de
l'ordinateur dont l'achat a été
autorisée il ya seulement deux ans tu
joues à tuer sur internet n'ont pas
l'internet c'est des jeux tu n'as pas
internet ici tous les cubains pense
qu'il faut plus d'ouverture parce qu'un
système qui dure depuis cinquante ans et
qui ne donne pas de résultat tu doit le
changer totalement en attendant les
touristes sont la bouée de sauvetage
économique des cubains ils représentent
la deuxième source de revenus du pays
avant
son rang
[Musique]
dernier jour de pêche dernière chance
pour gérard norbert rodolfo et georgi
aucun des trente bateaux n'a pris
davantage définitif
[Musique]
l'ex toi ce matin il faut pas beaucoup
de poissons je vois on a des cannes à
l'eau
de l'espoir
gérard décide de changer de zone pour se
rapprocher de la côte
regarde c'est par là qu'il ya du poisson
ici ils sont tous là vers l'est pas par
ici c'est par là que ça pêche
[Musique]
à la catastrophe
les heures passent et le soleil tape dur
brusquement les moulinets fils une
grosse touche l'espoir revient montrent
dangereux le barracuda avec ses dents
pointues mais aucun intérêt ce n'est pas
un poisson à rostre il ne va pas leur
rapporter 2 points
la radio les rappelle à la réalité
il ya un bateau qui a fait une prise il
y en a un autre qui vient de serrer et
qui est en train de travailler
[Musique]
cela se passe sur ce bateau le tiburones
j'allais dans le combat là
l'aller en train d'être humain
l'équipage grec et c'est une femme heidi
jaffres audi qui a engagé le combat
contre un gros marlins elle va le
ramener à bord après 40 minutes d'effort
je tiens bien soutient bien c'est bon je
tiens à vue de nez la bête pèse dans les
40 kilos je leur lâche maintenant allez
salut à la prochaine
marquez est relâché marc est relâché
combien ils ont eu deux non je crois
qu'il n'en a aucun
c'est mort
[Musique]
le concours est maintenant terminé a
très très déçu on sera ni très très très
déçu alors cette journée surtout ni la
chance d'avoir les poissons de la ligue
si on avait pu
des champions dès les premiers les
poissons bien dire
pêcheurs tout perdu
comme ça
prochaine
gérard pense déjà aux prochains tournois
vainqueur l'équipage espagnol du pilar
qui a pêché le premier poisson les
visitation les russes arrivent second
les américains franck et joseph sont
heureux c'était leur première
participation il s'en tire plutôt bien
on est quatrième sur 33 bateaux c'est
pas mal non
à la havane il n'y a pas d'argent à
gagner à la différence des autres
tournois de pêche internationaux
richement dotée sponsorisés l'équipage
espagnol brandi la coupe mais elle va
rester à cuba jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit à
nouveau remporté trois fois les français
conservent leur record est à un moment
de grande émotion parce qu'on l'a gardé
un nom en france et de la savoir ici
maintenant je pense que c'est quelque
chose de magnifique
et de toute façon elle reviendra en
france pour me faire confiance
quittez pas
tout s'achève sur un air de salsa l'an
prochain cuba aura peut être changé
le blocus américain pourrait s'alléger
le poids sans lui jouera toujours à
cache cache
[Musique]